I still remember when I the first time
went to Pi data I was a peer student I
was lucky I got a free ticket from the
pie ladies and I think back then I was
like trying to brush off my python
skills wanting to get a data science
position and was very keen on using all
this new machine learning Technologies
and learn about this and I guess back
then I probably would have asked like
why should I care about clean code and
maybe I would have not gone to this talk
and now a few years later I've worked in
different data science teams with
different code repositories and I've
also worked with engineers and often
that work with data scientists and often
it's more like why don't they care about
clean code so I've talked with so many
engineers and it's like oh my goodness
this code base of the data sign it's a
lot bunch of spaghetti code and I
remember my brother recently software
engineer also switched to work with data
scientists and then I asked like how is
it going like how do you like Python and
he was like my goodness these data
scientists they want to put Jupiter
notebooks into production like what a
mess
um and I think there's one one reason I
think why that is that often data
scientists don't care so much about
their code is that very often our main
output isn't actually a code that wants
in production but very often it's a
research document that outlines our
finding we have some Jupiter notebook we
test some assumptions we try out some
different models and maybe in the end
our conclusion is actually this approach
doesn't make sense uh this yeah
currently we need to wait for more data
or maybe it's just some number in a
presentation some slide some pie chart
or something so it's really not always
code that runs in production and so
because code is not the main output We
Care a bit less about it and we tell
ourselves these lies like I'm only going
to run this query once and this is
probably not going to change and no
one's going to need this again and yeah
especially with someone else's that
didn't quite work out it's like okay we
won't run this again and maybe Yachts
that you have the hope that you can just
deploy The Notebook to production maybe
copy paste some stuff but the reality
looks very differently in the end what
happens is that someone asks like oh can
you check if it also how what happens if
we only restrict to this group of people
and maybe you have some idea to come up
with you want to change some small
things and also very common and a
favorite of mine is like someone says oh
can you have a look at this old notebook
this old coat bath that a former
co-worker left and that back then we
didn't really have the capacity to do
but now we think it's a good idea to
look at it again and maybe implement it
and yeah deploying a notebook is
probably also not a good idea
um so I think yeah one thing with code
is that in the end we read code more
often than we write it and it means that
if we have dirty code that is hard to
understand it slows that down slows us
down it takes much more time to
understand if you need to go through
multiple files to see what is actually
happening there and then also it becomes
much harder to change it so if at some
point business says like hey we actually
realize we need to change something here
The Business rules it can be very hard
if you have to trade through multiple
fights to make this change and if you
have a very big jupyter notebook a lot
of spaghetti code it's not so much
easier to hide bugs in there
and I think one last reason why
especially data scientists should care
more about Clean Pro or good coding
practice is that it also makes
reproducibility easier if your code is
in a clean structure
okay so now I hope you agree with me
that it's good to have code that is easy
to read and I just want to go through a
few things that I think helped to make
code easier to read so one of the more
important ones and probably also very
difficult one is like that it's good to
have meaningful names so this one for
example this example functions it's hard
to understand what it does the variable
names are very short and super generic
there is some magic number in there that
you don't know what it is
very commonly what happens if you start
writing or learning about coding people
tell you it's good to add comments and
so you just add a comment and it's like
okay now we know that this calculates a
new price
but it's still not very helpful
so a much better solution to this is to
use very descriptive names that are
longer and this also has on the added
bonus that we can actually use we can
search for these names in our code base
good luck if you want to search for the
variable named K
and in this case we also don't need the
comment anymore we can just explain the
code through our names and here then it
becomes clear we want to Discount some
prices so I work with Hotel data uh of
10 so now we ought to know where the 0.9
came from it's
um yeah for the discount
and we also avoid generic names like
transform item that don't really tell us
much
yeah another good thing and I think this
is a very popular one especially for
data scientists you do write some code
and you do a lot of like data
Transformations and it just grows very
organically and then you have this very
long function that
um yeah you add some comments somewhere
to the different sections so that you
see now a bit what happens but a much
better solution would be to structure
this long code into shorter functions
and then each function then can also the
name of the function can tell us what
actually happens here so this is also a
bit of a pet peeve of mine that I think
comments most comments are bad so
especially they tend to go stay so if
you work with some old code base and
someone was very kind or thought kind
and they added many comments and you
read them and they just don't make sense
anymore because the code evolved but the
comments did not
so my rule of thumb is always to try to
explain the what with the code itself in
the function name Institute variable
name Etc and keep the comments to only
explain the why like why are we doing
this weird magic trick here
um so yeah
um yeah and this one is a bit more
complicated I think like maybe a bit
more abstract but in the end kind of the
overruling principle at least for me
it's about to avoid mixing different
abstraction layers so in this uh this
example the code for example we have one
function compute features which probably
does a bunch of uh important things
somewhere in there and then we have some
very low level function that is some
string transformation and some filtering
of some certain IDs and a much better
solution would be to group operations
together that have the same level of
abstraction and so use this to structure
the code into different abstraction
hierarchies
and the same answer how it's for the
variable names what I showed before if
we have a very generic function then of
course we can have very generic names if
we have more specific functions we want
to have more specific names
so probably many of you have already
heard some of these principles maybe you
already read about these or you already
know them intuitively but it's often
very difficult to find the time for this
and especially if then your product
manager wants to see results and your
results is not actually code it's
sometimes can be difficult to prioritize
this or find the time
and I think this is something where the
data science perspective can help a bit
so what we can do is we can try to find
ways to measure the code complexity or
the how clean our code is and once we
have data from our measurements we can
visualize these and with visualizations
and the measurement data we can also
then prioritize clean like how to to
improve our code
so I think this been uh yeah very
commonly used sense you can only improve
what you measure I don't know who
actually said it I think it's a bit
overused but it is true that to some
degree that if you can measure something
it can help you to
to improve
so this brings me to uh yeah my second
part by like measuring code complexity
so what we can do is we can use some
heuristics that help us to measure code
complexity which gives us like a proxy
on our code quality
so a very easy one is functioning so you
can just count the lines your function
has and if it's very long that's a good
indicator that you should probably
refactor you can also check the number
of input and output parameters so this
is all relatively easy to check and
count
all right then the next one is the
cognitive complexity so in this one one
way to measure how complex a function is
like how much mental load we need to
understand what is happening is we can
count the increments for breaks in the
flow so like every time there's an if
else statement or like a for Loop or a
nested for Loop this is a break in the
linear flow of the program so the more
increments we have the more nested the
the function is and the more difficult
it is to understand it
and then this one is kind of hinting on
this uh yeah the different abstraction
layers of it like in very small yeah
scope so this there's a file you can
check that you only have generic
variable names if the function is very
small so if um
so that like the more the bigger the
function is the more scope the you
should have more specific names and not
use this very generic terms like items
right Etc
and then this one the last one is about
expression complexity I mean A good rule
of thumb is that if your expression goes
over multiple lines you should probably
split it but this is basically about
trying to see how long is your
expression like how complex is it how
many Expressions do you put together uh
so for example in this Panda statement
it becomes very difficult what we are
actually trying to check here
so the good news is that all of these
are available as flag 8 plugins so we
don't really have to do that much work
um the yeah one I mean flake is great
you can put into your CI pipeline but
the disadvantage is that it's only
giving you like a binary number like
your code fails or it passes and if you
have some old code base or you're just
starting out on this journey uh this can
be a lot of work like your whole code
base might be a big mess and then it can
be a bit difficult to introduce these
flakes because your whole code's just
gonna yeah just a mess and it's just
gonna fail everything and you don't want
to go and improve everything all at once
or you well then the other option is you
just make this threshold very high for
everything to pass and then well you
kind of lose benefit
um so what I did I did make some
wrappers on these flake functions to
actually collect the the numbers that
the flakers use for their binary Flags
so I yeah I computed some complexity
heuristics um like just some wrappers
around these flake functions
and in my case I just have a Jupiter
notebook so which uh we as a team
decided is good enough and I started in
a Google sheet so you needs might vary
so depending on how how you need it you
might want to run it more often so in
our case we decided that it's good
enough to run it once every two months
to see
and and yeah this then gives us some
data that we can visualize so these are
two repositories from my team and we
cannot see like okay the this is the
average complexity over all functions in
this code base so the second one is
steadily declining so I think uh it's
good that we like having this in mind
with the that we want to have good code
and then the blue one the top one was
one of our old code base that no one
really wanted to touch and some of my
colleagues went and uh improved it and
you can see that the complexity
decreased by quite a bit
the other way that we can then use this
data is that we can
um like I said I store it in a Google
sheet so we cannot see some highlighting
and then this can help us to
to prioritize to see okay which files
functions are actually like the worst
functions and which one should we tackle
first so here we see this main function
is uh quite long and it's high cognitive
complexity so this one would be a good
candidate to refactor
so what we did in our team is we look at
this like once months or once every two
months and then discuss which kind of
functions we want to tackle which one
want to we want to prioritize and we set
aside around like two hours a month per
person
and this already has yeah quite a big
impact on our team so when we refactored
this one so this was the blue line from
before you can see now it's green I mean
it doesn't say much but um my colleagues
also say that it's indeed much nicer not
to work with this coach
so this brings me already to the end of
my talk and I hope you didn't come here
expecting some magic Solutions some neat
trick that's going to solve all your
code problems
um because I think in the end and it
comes it's a lot about culture so you
have to foster a clean code culture in
your team if you want to have good code
so what I presented here is a bit more
like a process and I think this process
definitely can help to Foster this
culture
so as I mentioned the way we do this we
meet like uh once a month once every two
months and then just sing together have
a look which cut which code we think
needs Improvement and kind of hand out
like some everyone grabs like okay I'm
going to have a look at this part
we have set aside like some time and I
think one big benefit that we saw is
that we use pair programming I think
especially if you have some old code
base that everyone no one really wants
to touch because it's such a mess and
everyone knows it it can be really nice
if you do it in a pair programming so
you don't have to wait through the dirty
code alone and I think this results like
one of the feedbacks for my team that
they say this was one of the biggest
benefits that through the pair
programming they also really shared the
knowledge about the code and really also
improved their coding skills if you pair
like two new and more senior
together
yeah another way how you can foster code
clean code culture in the previous team
we read the clean code book in a reading
reading group at work
and this really helped us to kind of
yeah get more see a bit more like what
things are out there so I only presented
like some of the main
um yeah concepts of clean code but of
course they're like more
and especially just kind of reading
together and then after reading one
chapter checking like okay how bad is
our code for these terms uh really this
does help to Foster this culture
and with that I conclude my talk so I
um thank you Corey for very interesting
and so very Hands-On um topics with lots
of memes we all love to use and I can
see it here that we have a very Lively q
a sections so first off are you sharing
these flight 8 wrappers for trackings
they sound perfect for our team
um yes so I have them in this GitHub
repository called complexity and I have
to confess that they also didn't start
out very clean they were like some quick
and dirty wrappers in the beginning so I
know there I did clean them up for this
talk specific but yeah you can have a
look there
awesome
um yeah someone else wants to ask what
do you think about dark strings for
every glass method when to use them
a good question so I think doc strings
they can be great
um but it really depends on the function
so as I mentioned a code like comments
do you have the problem that they can
you stay the same how it's also for dog
strings also by the way for typing so
I've seen some type pins that were
really lying about what was happening in
the function
um the way we do in our team is that
like the smaller the function the less
doctoring you want to have you probably
need so and then keep the dog strength
for the more yeah higher higher level
functions
so it's good tips
um another questions
I had the problem of seeing Health too
much inner functions because there are
so many possibilities
possibilities at the beginning uh too
much uh I guess like you know see a lot
of complexity into function and he say
because for her say she said there's so
many possibilities therefore have very
long names how can I try to improve this
yeah that's a good question so the way
understood is like about if we
preferring like long names with the
short names uh I do like short names
because I like Short Line lengths but
there is then the trade-off that indeed
um you should not compromise readability
and I guess if it's about readability
sometimes you have to buy the apple and
then you just go for the long names
I see and one of another questions I
have which tool you think would be used
to identify the level of code coupling
or to age in separations of concerns
um good question I have not looked at
this
um so feel free to share if you have any
tools so I'm not aware of any tools for
that like I remember I also looked up
for how dry the chord is like if there's
repetition in the code I think there was
somewhere something but it didn't seem
very applicable so
um it's a good point there's definitely
so many issues that you will not be able
to catch with these chord complexities
they really act more as heuristics to
get a feeling like if what direction
your code is going
it's good to know anything another
question for the communities
another one one another questions are
there any types of comments
oh yeah are there any types of comments
that you think are okay to use what to
do if you need to document the reason
for decisions made during data
processings
so don't get me wrong I'm not against
types or comments so I do use typings
and comments as well I think it's just
like we have to be aware that comments
are not the solution to having
explainable code
um let's say
[Music]
um
I'm sorry can you repeat the last part
uh What uh what to do if you need to
document the reasons for decisions made
during data processing
um so I mean this kind of depends where
where this decision is in later needed
so I think some just a decision for us
goes more into a research doc that we
share with the business
with product managers Etc but indeed
like many kind of especially like the
weird decisions
um or some code decisions where we copy
pasted something homesick overflow that
was hard to understand so this then I
usually comment like okay we did this
way we copy paste it from here
um also because I think these are often
then the parts if it looks weird someone
in the future might look like why does
it look so weird I'm going to change
this and then it's going to break so I
think these are the places where it's
good to have a comment
um to document your decisions
that's a good point
um yeah a lot of people are very curious
to try the GitHub link but it seems like
it's not working it's not public maybe I
have yeah maybe I have to put a probably
a good point I'm gonna do this after the
talk
awesome thanks Corey
um next questions
um do you do you have any experience in
using lightning on GitHub using what
linting
um
actually not my company currently is
using gitlab so
what do you mean like using linting in a
CI pipeline
um I think this person wants to
especially ask about GitHub yeah
um yeah I don't know I mean we do have
linting in our code in our CI pipeline
uh I I do think it's nice I personally
also like automatic vometer it does work
for me but
I I know that there's always lots of
discussion about linting stuff so
it always lives on you every day and
maybe that's something you want to try
later on
our next question are there alternatives
to flick eight and what are the pros and
cons
there are definitely some other
commercial truths so I had one from a
team that also
um used I think there's like a GitHub
integration that also measures this code
complexity
so in a way it does very similar things
to what I do I think maybe without the
well the customization data processing
if you want to do anything on your code
complexity data but there are some tools
available that
can also do this
do you have any examples the
specifically what you want to share or I
think one two that does it I think it's
what's called code coverage so it
integrates nicely also with GitHub but
it's a commercial product so you have to
pay
I see
um that's interesting and so there's a
lot of other questions about code
complexities so another person wants to
ask they are instances where reducing
code complexities might affect code
efficiency based on your experience when
would this be worth it
I don't think there's a general rule
when it's worth it when not so I
remember I think there was like one talk
um before about speeding up python where
he also mentioned uh naive code is
usually not the most efficient one but
it can be very readable so I like that
he mentioned
um they're like some easy plug-and-play
ways in like using for example number
that make then the whole code easier to
read
um like it still stays easily easy to
read because you're using basically the
naive implementation and you're just
switching out some code some types and I
think if that's possible that's a great
solution but of course this is a
trade-off and it will depend heavily on
your use case so of course if it's
business critical if it costs you a few
thousand uh I don't know dollars or so
then it might be worth to go for the
less readable more efficient version but
yeah I think that's really up to the use
case
so the question is as the answer is it
depends it depends yes she says
everything
um but thank you for sharing your
perspectives another questions about
code metrics do you think that creating
the code metrics with every PR would
help the team or is it going to be
counterproductive do you think that
creating the code metrics with every PR
would help the teams or it's going to be
covered productive
um
so I think one thing that I did I mean
this is kind of more using kind of so I
think one thing we did is that if you
then have like a decent code complexity
in in your code base so that you can
start using the flakers as they're
supposed to be then it can be nice way
to have them in your in your PR TI
pipeline to check like okay that the
code does not deteriorate
um you cannot include checks I think it
can be nice I think especially the color
coding often can have like a good
benefit if you see it's like this code
that you're trying to merge has an
orange complexity so often it's not so
much about the number but kind of giving
the colors and I do think that people
are a bit more reluctant to merge
something if it's orange there's also a
lot of discussion I had some discussion
with the guys setting up the pipelines
in my company that I wanted to have some
flakes to only show Orange but you can
still merge it because it was a big pain
in the beginning when he introduced all
of them uh some people's like no if it's
orange but you can say merge it people
are going to ignore it I think people do
not necessarily ignore it but I think
it's also something that where it comes
back again to culture like this is a bit
part also about culture that if you do
your PR review it it help if everyone in
the team has this kind of culture of
paying attention to code complexity to
the readability and then to mentions
like hey maybe you could improve this
function by changing this name like this
is really hard to understand so I think
this is
cup
probably how you want to do it and yeah
finishing it all tied back to like
cultures yeah you say
um another questions quickly about
gamifications how do your user react on
the gamification of Pipeline and a graph
by pi reverse
how do your user react on the
gamification of pilot and a graph by pi
reverse
um
I'm not sure what pi reverse is
um gamification so I think the feedback
in my team was very positive that it's
nice if you can visualize the code the
code really improved because I think
especially with code quality the results
aren't always that tangible so I think
this is also why maybe it's sometimes a
bit difficult to convince your product
project manager that you need to invest
some time in this and I think this is
just very satisfying for yourself if you
see it's like look now we really see
this um the code quality improved quite
a bit and also something that you can
show
and
another thing about complexities in
terms of list in terms I think in terms
of list and dictionary comprehension how
do you measure the cognitive
complexities
I don't know how to measure cognitive
complexity I think as I say these
heuristics definitely don't cover all
cases you can still do very dirty things
that are hard to understand that will
not be covered by any of these
heuristics I presented uh so that's why
they're called heuristics
um again I think this is where it comes
down to foster a culture of having nice
good code and also for like a culture of
learning and try wanting to improve your
code
is work in progress
another questions I want to split the
function into smaller bits but have
trouble organizing it properly both to
understand the use and also to reuse the
code how you have any advice for how to
organize it
well no one said it's going to be easy
so
um well there is still some work to do
like it's not it doesn't the code
doesn't organize itself so I guess
that's going to be your job as a
developer or data scientist
um so yeah I think this is the part
where you probably need to think what
makes most sense
um yeah I don't think I have really any
tips for that I know that there's some
discussion notes like how much sense it
makes to reuse functions a lot because
there's also can increase
maintainability problems if you reuse
functions in very different contexts but
this really depends on the use case and
I think this is kind of like the part
where you really need to think a bit
like how do you separate the different
parts of the code
last question that we can take do you
have any recommendation for material
beyond the more basic use case for
example a good repo structures or
interactions or functions or classes
I guess a good recommendation would be
to be consistent
um I've but I think this also for me
finds hard because like I usually came
into a company that already has existing
code structure and it doesn't I think
often it doesn't make sense to change
things because that's going to be the
math to just like reorganizing stuff so
but often good case is to just work with
what you have and see how you can
organize in this structure
um
yeah I had to say I think be consistent
I do like for data science I think
they're like some cookie cutter
approaches that um that already provide
a good structure for repositories which
I think is very nice but of course it
doesn't always fit all projects but it
can give a really good like give a good
guidance what which direction to go on I
see that's good chips and I think that's
the end of the hotel today everyone
please give a warm welcome
[Applause]